isn't it grand to be able to have a
legitimate drink after all this year
[Music]
i believe this is prohibition 2.0
we've seen this movie before so it's a
comfortable feeling to understand how
big the industry is going to go from
here and how we want to position
ourselves for it ben covler is the
founder and ceo of green thumb
industries which is one of the nation's
largest cannabis companies ben kovaler
is an heir to the jim beam fortune his
great-grandfather became president of
jim beam distilling company in the 30s
after prohibition ended
transforming a business from the illegal
market to a legal one is in kovler's
blood although he's the first in his
family to do it in the cannabis industry
learning the beam story growing up my
grandfather taught me a ton about
branding and the consumer and how to
think about that one of the lessons we
learned earlier was you know square
bottle square shake it's kind of a fun
thing to say but
part of the brand being square bottle
square shake this is an honest delivery
and just that nuance of oh my god the
shape of a glass bottle of the booze
actually matters to the consumer to the
brand i think you see a commonality
amongst our brands of a simple idea and
a simple promise
we try to focus on that for example dog
walkers
which we invented in-house is a mini
joint suitable for a dog walk there's an
element of a charitable component to
more dog shelters and treating animals
humanely it's easy to understand that we
talk about enjoy the journey which is
obviously you know it's life is the
journey not the destination and so
trying to remind folks of that maybe if
they're on their dog walk or just having
a walk
and a joint is a good thing for that
walk so the highest level it's a product
that consumers want so they're finding a
way to get it so let's take bathtub gin
and moonshine the equivalent of the
illegal product uh have become jack
daniels jim beam jose cuervo
and we believe weed in a baggie will
become rhythm vivo incredibles as new
york prepares to launch adult use sales
in 2023 green thumb industries is
expanding its cultivation in the state
with a brand new 200 000 square foot
facility about an hour away from
manhattan
this particular plot of land has been
witness to more than a century of
america's changing views on drugs and
crime in 1912 it was home to the new
york city farm which was an early drug
and alcohol treatment center in the 30s
it was the new york state training
school for boys a reform school
dedicated to rehabilitating troubled
youth from the city
and by the 70s it had been converted
into the mid-orange correctional
facility the state-run prison and the
irony that cannabis will be grown on
this particular plot of land is not lost
on anyone we really think it's a full
circle moment for the industry we're
going to take a place in a site that
used to lock up people for cannabis now
we're going to employ them to produce
cannabis